philippe emmanueli médecin un français
qui est installé à barcelone
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
alors parlez nous d'abord de cette de la
situation en espagne globalement et bien
écoutez ici la situation tend plutôt à
s'améliorer avec des chiffres parfois
contradictoires d'un jour à l'autre
c'est à dire parfois on voit des petits
pics de réalimentation des
contaminations sur une journée et puis
le lendemain ce arobas alors on ne sait
pas si ça traduit une tendance lourde ou
si c'est lié toujours à la disponibilité
des tests mais on reste dans une phase
un petit peu d'attentes et
d'incertitudes par rapport à ces
chiffres
alors on boit pour faire un parallèle
avec la france en espagne de confinement
est retardée à à madrid à barcelone dans
plusieurs régions là où il ya
probablement plus de densité s'est
justifié selon vous alors c'est vrai
qu'ici le gouvernement central a pris en
compte des critères extrêmement clair
quand effectivement au lancement des
phases de déconfinement c'est à dire la
saturation des services de soins la
disponibilité des tests et l'aptitude à
la fois des transports publics et des
entreprises à mettre en oeuvre les
mesures barrières à une grande échelle
mais ce qu'on voit apparaître en espagne
peut-être également comme en france
c'est une politisation du déconfinement
vous le savez en espagne la santé et
régionalisée et on a assisté il y à ces
derniers jours à une passe d'armes assez
sévère entre le la directrice des
services de santé madrilène et le
pouvoir central et sa directrice a
d'ailleurs démissionné parce que elle
n'était pas d'accord avec les décisions
du pouvoir central
et puis aujourd'hui c'est l'andalousie
qui ne comprend pas pourquoi
reste en phase 0 et pourquoi elle est la
seule à faire l'objet d'une mesure
globale territoriale alors que dans
d'autres communautés
il y à un traitement plus fin de
déconfinement par territoire et c'est
vrai que tout cela laisse augurer de
règlement de compte politique car bien
entendu tout ceci opposent parfois les
régions et des communautés en fonction
de leurs différentes couleurs politiques
vous parlez de politisation justement du
déconfinement mais quels sont les
critères sanitaires qui sont prises en
compte en espagne en donc les critères
sanitaires c'est ce que je vous disais à
l'instant ils sont essentiellement liées
aux capacités existantes des hôpitaux à
absorber de nouveaux malades du code
vide à la disponibilité des tests et à
la capacité des communautés autonomes à
mettre en place les mesures barrières à
la fois au niveau des entreprises et au
niveau des moyens de transports publics
alors vous parlez des tests justement où
en et l'espagne à ce niveau les masques
également le portent des masques
alors bien sûr il y à une amélioration
dans la mise à disposition des masques
qui sont par exemple distribué à
l'entrée de tous les transports publics
il est aujourd'hui à barcelone facile de
trouver des masques en pharmacie et ses
masques font l'objet effectivement d'un
prix réglementé au niveau national de 96
centimes et j'ai pu le constater par
moi-même
on peut aujourd'hui trouver facilement
des masques par exemple à barcelone
concernant les tests c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué d'une part parce que une
partie de cette action avec ce sont
accessibles uniquement à travers les
laboratoires privés et dans ce cas le
coût de ces thèses qui n'est pas pris
forcément en charge varient de quelques
dizaines d'euros à plus de 120 euros
finalement on a l'impression qu'on est
un peu dans la même situation ici en
france puisque vous parlez du prix du
masque à l'unité s'agissant aussi du
bilan humain
on a dépassé en espagne et 26 mille
morts avec plus de 220 mille cas
recensés là encore comment comment vous
expliquez que l'espagne la france
l'italie sont les trois pays avec aussi
le royaume uni très touché par le col et
19 ans en europe
écoutez c'est vrai qu'à ce stade je
pense qu'il est difficile de donner une
explication et essai avec le recul avec
les études épidémiologiques qu'on
trouvera peut-être des éléments pour
répondre à cette question ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on sait que le coc vide
a tué en forte majorité les populations
âgées les populations institutionnalisé
en maison de retraite et en espagne
particulièrement l'organisation des
maisons de retraite c'est que cela a pu
favoriser effectivement une forte
mortalité institutionnels merci beaucoup
à vous philippe emmanuelli je rappelle
que vous êtes médecin installé à
barcelone merci pour cette intervention
en direct sur arte france